one of the things that technology can
really help companies do is figure out
how they have incredible product market
fit not just in the early stages but
then as they continue to grow and scale
and keep innovating and the challenge
there for most organizations is how sort
of misaligned the sales in the r d team
naturally is because of where they live
the go to market team is sort of living
around the universe's sales force and
talking to customers all the time and
your r d organization is probably out
there you know writing code and
orienting around atlassian geotype
services and it's very very difficult to
actually create the seamless
interconnected tissue between these
worlds which you very much need if
you're going to put products in market
that you're very confident that people
can engage with when you're not there to
shepherd them sort of during that world
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret court ventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel
j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today i'm with matt darrow talking about
enterprise
software matt is the ceo and co-founder
of viven
matson is an enterprise software leader
with experience growing businesses
building global teams and delivering
products before founding vivint he
worked at zora big machines and deloitte
i love turkey california and it sounds
like the work they're doing is
fascinating on multiple fronts
purchasing
consumer behavior is shifting rapidly
over these last few decades and i'm
looking forward to learning a little bit
more about this piece from you and today
running even uh you're
you have so much interesting experience
for from different
um from different organizations that
you've been a part of and and viven is
obviously doing extraordinarily
well with some some great news lately so
congratulations uh for that uh tell me a
little bit about yourself matt what what
really excites you
in in you know in the world or in your
own career
yeah it's a it's a it's a big question
and uh yeah you know stop the squeeze
into 20 minutes i think i think for me
you know
i i'm i'm always looking a to do the
hard thing uh which is why i think i i
went down ultimately the professional
journey of becoming a founder but that
parlays into my personal life too
whether or not it's you know climbing
mountains or learning to become a pilot
or you know studying advanced degrees
and getting masters of science and
engineering this has been a common
thread sort of throughout my time and
tenure
um and i think professionally one of the
things that excites me if i take you
know sort of that part aside just who i
am and what makes my dna
um the other thing that i that i really
love to focus on it's like how do you
build b2b companies that just look and
feel different then i think a lot of the
mold that comes out of silicon valley
and ultimately getting to a place that
you've got an incredible culture
incredible group of people um and you're
doing things you're setting the stage in
a way that other companies can follow
like for us
we were 100 remote company before the
pandemic necessarily made that um sort
of a requirement or fashionable we do a
lot of investment in culture and mental
health and awareness we do a lot of
different things and how we organize as
a group and a person uh within our four
walls so i think for us you know for me
personally um i love a i love a great
challenge whether that's a physical
challenge a mental challenge
professional challenge um and along the
way i'm trying to do things that uh
maybe other companies aren't quite
pioneering but others can potentially
look to for for guidance and to follow
incredible and how do you find yourself
looking into the buying space
as a as sort of a pain point that you
deeply care about
well this uh you know starting vivint
wasn't necessarily a foregone conclusion
so i
um you know even like yourself with an
engineering background after doing my
master's in engineering i was writing
computer software in a very small
laboratory all by myself for 10 hours a
day and i very quickly realized this
probably isn't a long-term career for
myself so i figured well i need to sort
of get out of this space of being uh
sort of very very isolated and and was
going to see what was out there and i
joined uh deloitte consulting very early
on in my days and that's actually how i
got into the world of b2b enterprise
applications i knew nothing about sap
nothing about oracle nothing about
salesforce.com
and i learned it all there and i started
to really fall in love with this uh with
this area in this world which is
software for some of the world's largest
and leaning businesses the problem sets
were really challenging um the
opportunities were really interesting
how you could actually change the
behavior of a big company
and i also very quickly realized doing
deployments and being on the post sales
side of the house
also was not for me at all like we were
writing custom software developments for
sap and you know doing year-long plus
implementations deployments and that's
when i found my way into i call it the
the best profession in technology that
nobody's ever heard of which is sales
engineering and at big machines at the
time go to abel their ceo
he had hired me gave me my first gig as
an se and i'd been in that career then
for the next 10 plus years and it was
all of those core learnings that i had
on that next journey whether or not it
was companies that would get acquired or
companies that we would take public
um those core learnings form the basis
for what would become vivint which was
all the tools and the technologies that
i wish that i had as i was building my
teams and running my businesses
they just didn't exist yet so there's
this great opportunity to have these
sort of first of their kind products in
the marketplace and what i saw during
that time
was this big change in how b2b selling
um
actually needs to evolve from a world of
sort of magic quadrants and golf and
fancy dinners to you know folks that are
very autonomous independent uh the
product is really the center of the
universe and that changes the dynamic
for so many different companies too so
it's a very very short uh sort of story
around not only my founder journey but
where i went from being very a deep
specialist in engineering to say hey i
actually want to do something a little
bit more customer focused a little bit
more business savvy focus and i found my
way into this amazing career that uh is
really starting to come into its own um
that can really change the way that a
b2b company not only goes to market but
there's a great opportunity for
technologies to actually help it and
help those businesses too
so maybe can you give me a little bit
more of an overview as to how
b2b
sales are have taken place traditionally
how they're taking place today sort of
what are the big shifts that are
happening and and then obviously
transitioning into vivin and how
technology is now making things much
easier and better
yeah well so my prior life before
founding vivint
you know i was always at b2b companies
of different shapes and sizes before
that was zora their you know publicly
traded subscription billing system i was
there from very very early days to the
ipo before that big machines which was
configure price quote really tackling
the sort of quote to cash cycle
ultimately they got uh purchased by
oracle and a lot of these companies you
know our sales motions and tactics
were the tried and true motions that
folks like ptc and bnc and oracle and
even salesforce to some extent
um made famous back in the early 2000s
even late 90s
which was very much again based on
relationships
and then also based on you know driving
the customer through your process and
then at the end because it's enterprise
software hoping that the delivery team
could somehow figure out how to make all
this stuff go live and you know the
customer actually gets some semblance of
value of the vision that you were
selling in the first place
and i think the big change even over the
last five years there's a bunch of
things that have hit us i think the
first is you know the pandemic has
affected so many things in our lives one
thing that it's really done is
it's made buyers really really
comfortable operating autonomously and
independently uh the second thing is and
you actually see this when you look at
all the great publicly traded sas
companies out there you know over half
of them have motions that start with
their products first so like half of the
publicly traded sas market cap is
actually on companies that make their
product the entry point into a
conversation with their business and
then you also see
brand new sales compensation models
actually started to come out where that
old world of hey i do a big million
dollar contract and hopefully deloitte
and accenture and the gsis will make
this customer successful 18 months from
now um but yeah i've i've gotten my
commission check already so i don't need
to worry about it that's right away so
like a snowflake the reps and the team
and stuff like you don't even get paid
unless the customer's consuming the
service so what all that like the big
big change for me
is that buyers now are pretty darn sales
proof you can't medic them into
submission they want transparency
in the product in the process and that's
putting enormous pressure on every b2b
company to give them immediate access to
products that just have incredible
product market fit to be able to take
the people that are the true experts in
their solutions and actually not have
that be a conversation 10 steps down the
qualification process but the first
thing that happens
and then that has a whole host of other
things that need to occur which is well
then how do you allow that to happen
when you're not in the room or on the
zoom do that organically do that
autonomously and do that with extreme
transparency and collaboration right
that's the really the opportunity in b2b
right now is how do i address the needs
of these salesproof buyers by giving
them a different experience because
going through you know sort of a
traditional sales mode and methodology
isn't isn't what uh folks are very
interested in anymore
so are you helping teams
reflect better on on the core values of
the products and and take you know
existing value propositions and existing
um you know features of the product and
then
and then create creating a better better
channel for for transmitting that
information or for communicating that
because it sounds like you're saying you
know the old sales approach where you're
sort of making them surrender that's
that's i think of the past now let's see
how we can actually take the core values
that you're providing and bring them to
life is is that sort of the the way that
the world is shifting
well i think what one uh super tangible
example would be in my prior lives it
was nearly uh a fireable offense to
allow the prospect to engage with your
product and service before the deal was
closed
interesting that was because a whole
host of challenges around he would it
would add steps it would add time it
would you know is it going to uncover
something that potentially you can't
deliver on so there there's this there
was this sort of that that different way
of being was that you know hey we would
paint a great rosy picture of the world
and then hopefully you know we can
figure out how to make it all work so
you know that no longer flies with the
sales proof fire so for us
one of the things that technology can
really help companies do is figure out
how they have incredible product market
fit not just in the early stages but
then as they continue to grow and scale
and keep innovating and the challenge
there for most organizations is how sort
of misaligned the sales in the r d team
naturally is because of where they live
the go to market team is sort of living
around the universe's sales force and
talking to customers all the time and
your r d organization is probably out
there you know writing code and
orienting around atlassian jira type
services and it's very very difficult to
actually create the seamless
interconnected tissue between these
worlds which you very much need if
you're going to put products in market
that you're very confident that people
can engage with when you're not there to
shepherd them sort of during that world
the second like very very large dynamic
too so that's one of the core things
that we focus on is like how do we
create an incredibly
near real-time or seamless
interconnected tissue between what we're
building and how we're taking it to
market so you can put products in market
that just have incredible fit that
customers are just really excited about
and then part two becomes
you know when we bought uh you know the
very very famous uh security monitoring
system sneak out there you know my
co-founding cto um the very very first
conversation that he had with somebody
in the sales engineering team at sneak's
side uh they were the expert right we
didn't need to know about the company
and their growth trajectory and their
market and how much funding they've
raised and you know who our you know
account manager might be we have very
very specific questions on how we
thought this would help us against the
two or three other competitors that we
were evaluating with and what's
happening is that there's this very big
change that's happening all these
companies that the folks that are the
true experts in the product and the
solution they're in demand like never
before this huge operational burden that
every b2b company is going through which
is how do i give them a consistent
workflow how do i how do i monitor and
measure what they're doing and the
impact that they're having that makes my
flywheel drive even faster those are two
very simple examples of some of the
things that we do for for a lot of our
clients
and so what is the actual product that
that vivint does with with these clients
in respect to that in respect to those
examples they just gave
yeah so for us um you know we have a
very similar long-term product strategy
that you know atlassian has or zendesk
might have or even salesforce to some
extent where we have a platform which
runs a whole family of products that are
can be used independently
right but when you use them together you
get this sort of this great halo effect
very similar to how i can be a jira user
without using ops genie or
without using confluence same thing for
us right you might come in and use hero
without using eval or eval without using
you know our third or fourth products
that we're bringing to market you know
over time too so for us
hero our very very first product that we
ever brought to market was really
focused on those first core two tenants
which is how do we create this
connective tissue between the c the
field and r d so we become the conduit
where all the sales post sales pre-sales
conversations are thrown into the world
of hero a bunch of data science said
that that we've got you know patents
that we're publishing on goes and it
clusters all this information ties it to
business value highlights the most
important things that you want to push
forward as capability sets and then
because we plug into the delivery system
when r d actually ships code in real
time as ci cd is taken off we go and we
reactivate the field these are the deals
the counts the customers that we should
go back and actually you know go back to
this is a huge area for us that allows
us to lift attainment for clients and
and and sort of in that mode in the
other core part of hero that's just part
of sort of the job of running your
business unit so for us like a client
like a snowflake or a dell or an
autodesk or whomever happens to be an
elastic surge um you know their whole
workflow and their process of how do we
engage these new salesproof buyers runs
on us the deliverables that we do with
them how we staff our teams how we
allocate resources how we measure the
impact um and and those two things
working in concert really forms the
basis of what our first offering hero
was and then eval right eval extended
that further to say well
when product becomes the center of your
universe that means every evaluation is
very hands-on so how do you and i come
together and agree on my requirements
and proving them out and knowing exactly
what i'm signing up for holding each
other accountable together and then
passing all that information downstream
for the rest of the organization to uh
to use once you actually sign on board
one of the things that i'm always
curious about these companies that have
multiple offerings that like you said
advance one advantage is that they can
use it independently because they serve
different use cases a a challenge that
they present is how do you create this
homogeneous
feeling of brand identity and trust
between the company and
viva and not the company and eval or the
company and heroes how do you create
that sort of brand identity where if
they use one product
they can then translate that trust and
brand um yeah brand trust to the other
features the other products
i think one big thing in the approach
that we've taken from the beginning is
how do we go and build organically
versus building through bolt-on
acquisition and in companies in my past
and prior lives i think because we had
took the approach of bolt-on acquisition
we ended up in the place that you're
sort of describing the look and feel is
different the lexicons are different the
data models are different the motions
are different even the potential buyers
are different too
and that causes a lot of that friction
so for us
you know getting to a point where you
know our internal r d team builds all of
our products and services that gives
this that gives them this sort of
amazing sort of
feel of how they just naturally work
together but the more important thing on
top of that is is our main persona and
champion is the same across all of our
products so
if you were the if you were the leader
of the pre-sales organization at
snowflake or at you know any one of our
clients a hashicorp or you know an octa
um you're the singular person that every
single one of our products is relevant
to
so we we have not only multiple ways to
enable your success but we have a really
great ongoing conversation with one
person that then when they use our
products and services more and more
users come into our world so product
people sales people customer success
people and uh but but because of who we
talk to the problems we solve the way
that our technologies work that's how we
uh that's how we seek to avoid i think
that challenge that a lot of folks run
into
so essentially and i miss me that each
of these products that you have you have
no dedicated teams working on them so
they're almost sort of startups within a
startup right
yeah the way that we've and we actually
went through that transformation
relatively recently here after you know
we we closed our our series uh c
fundraising round uh we announced it
back in may that we've got over 131
million raised to really tackle this
challenge and as our r d team is going
to you know 100 plus across product
engineering um we've moved from a mode
where you know sort of there's one
centralized area and and workflow for
development and now there's core pods
and thematic teams that allows us to go
and say hey these core folks in this
universe you know we might have three
four five pods working on hero
one or two on eval and as new products
come online it's a very very um sort of
organic way that you can see the group
of folks that have a self-contained
product engineering ux function that can
bring new offerings to market too
and it also sounds like an advantage
that you can transition folks within you
know within your organization to
different products that based on you
know needs or based on you know their
wanting to try out different things so
you also have the advantage of reducing
the churn potential of somebody who's
getting burned out on a specific product
or a feature that they're working on
yep exactly and then the engagement just
is it's it's just so much different
because now you have a collective core
unit that is working to solve the same
problems and has a mission of the
charter where i think again some
organizations that will run product and
engineering as separate pillars you know
engineering can sometimes feel like
you know either they're not necessarily
aligned with their product counterparts
so they can feel like um it's just the
queue of jira tickets that need to work
through the system and there's not as
much ownership in terms of the services
coming to market which uh org structures
can can play a big part of
interesting interesting so so what do
you get most excited about what you do
today if you're looking at the various
things that you get to deal with you're
working on a variety of products you're
working on building a crazy company and
what what are you getting most excited
about
um you know
to me i i loved the challenge of
not only creating a company from scratch
but we're building first of their kind
products in a brand new category i think
that's the most exciting piece for me
which is we weren't necessarily founders
that were looking for a business to
create and said well what's a hot market
that exists what are four or five
solutions that are maybe a little bit
antiquated let's build the modern
version the sixth version that's the
most modern version um that doesn't
excite me at all it's been done before
somebody else can tackle that challenge
i think for us
the creative process of saying there's a
whole greenfield opportunity of
individuals that need tools and
technologies to help them there's a way
that you can you can change the way that
every b2b company is going to market and
creating different experiences and you
do that by building first of their kind
products um that's what gets me going
every single day and like the sub to
that or it's relatively on even par is
doing that in a way where we really
think about culture and org structure
and and how we build the company so that
we don't follow the same patterns that i
think end up especially when you build a
business to business company could end
up with um you know politics and
bureaucracy and and a lot of the
friction that uh that companies end up
having over time
math such a such a cool story i love the
insights that you bring with you it
sounds like you have some really you
know deep foundational understandings of
how these how this market works and the
different pain points and the drawbacks
of this interaction uh with
business to business and um and
congratulations again on the on the
amazing milestones with all the
different products that you've built and
with the company as a whole so i look
forward to continue following the
journey and gaining more inspiration i
learned a lot from you so i appreciate
your time and thank you very very much
matt
thanks for having me this was great
appreciate thank you very much
you